haschisch in rauen mengen direkt
geliefert bis vor die haustür drogen
taxis werden gern auch im gangsta rap
lösung
drogenkuriere bestellt per messenger
chat direkt vor die haustüren ein taxi
aber woher kommen die drogen die in den
taxis verkauft werden und wie
funktioniert das geschäft dahinter
wir begeben uns auf spurensuche über
deutsche drogen taxis bis im
libanesischen hinterland wenn du 1000
quadratisch platz hast du kein risiko es
lässt sich immer verkaufen haschisch an
zu tun ist also risikofrei für den bau
eine reise dorthin wo haschisch
tonnenweise hergestellt wird
die libanon connect das geschäft mit den
drogen handy oder ich schieße hier ist
der hauptstadt kabul ich überzeuge mit
einer top qualität und einer schnellen
lieferzeit 0,5 gramm für 50 euro 3 gramm
für 250 euro
[Musik]
der beginn der recherche wir finden in
der messenger app telegramm verschiedene
gruppen chats hier werden ganz offen
drogen angeboten gras oder kokain per
taxi ist das tatsächlich so einfach wir
schreiben den dealer anfragen ob er auch
uns beliefern kann die antwort
20 minuten später ein auto fährt vor
darin zwei junge männer haben wir
miteinander geschrieben ja wollte
einfach einsteigen ja sofort zeigt er
uns ein halbes gramm koks preis 50 euro
lange sei er noch nicht dabei wenn wir
für ihn werben sagt er bekam wie rabatt
an der nächsten ecke lässt er uns wieder
raus das koks lassen wir drin
überall in deutschland sind koks und
gras leicht zu bekommen mit dem drogen
taxi oder beim dealer an der ecke wie
hier in berlin
ermittler bestätigen das geschäft werde
beherrscht von kriminellen mitgliedern
einzelner großfamilien aus dem libanon
und der türkei ein erheblicher anteil
der rohrstück minorität wurde auch aus
diesen kreisen begangen wenngleich sich
auch arabische großfamilien oder
krimineller in dem fall oder auch
clan-mitglieder die kriminell sind nicht
auf rauschgiftdelikte beschränken aber
es macht einen ganz großen teilort
oberstaatsanwalt ralph knispel betont
nur eine minderheit agiere kriminell
wir treffen uns mit einem älteren herren
einem libanesen er kennt die kriminellen
strukturen in berlin gut und will nicht
erkannt werden deshalb stellen wir das
interview nach die strafen in
deutschland sind lasch die lachen
ich habe einen freund der hat 110 kilo
koks hierher gebracht und verkauft er
zwölf jahre gekriegt dann hat er mit dem
staatsanwalt gesprochen und andere
verpfiffen
er kam nach zwei jahren frei hatte genug
geld er hat viele häuser gekauft in der
türkei und im libanon
davon lebt er bis heute er erinnert sich
so wie er fliehen in den 70er jahren
tausende vor dem bürgerkrieg im libanon
nach west berlin
sie werden geduldet dürfen aber nicht
arbeiten sprachkurse gibt es nicht
integration findet nicht statt kaum geld
viel langeweile
das habe kriminalität gefördert bilder
einer razzia von 1980 ein lokal in der
potsdamer straße treffpunkt
libanesischer heroinhändler die leute
waren neugierig auf geld dann fingen wir
an mit rauschgift erst schmuggelten sie
das haschisch in oliven und heroin in
schuhsohlen das geschäft wurde größer
ging vom vater zum sohn von derzeit 78
bis zum heutigen tag
bis heute sollen drogen aus dem libanon
nach deutschland kommen wir reisen
dorthin wollen wissen welche rolle das
land im internationalen drogenhandel
spielt beirut der libanon lebt vor allem
vom geld der 14 millionen libanesen die
im ausland wohnen
der staat ist schwach viele politiker
gelten als korrupt
nach tagelang vor gesprächen treffen wir
uns nachts mit einem dealer in den
straßen beiruts woher kommen all die
drogen das kokain kommt aus südamerika
haschisch aber produzieren wir hier in
den bann und die regierung lässt das zu
natürlich wissen sie davon
sie machen das ja erst möglich die sind
korrupt das heißt mit dem nötigen
schmiergeld kriegt man alle drogen raus
und rein ins land ja alle drogen aber es
kostet er nimmt uns mit in seine wohnung
da zeigt er uns frische ware kiloweise
haschisch
es kommt aus der gegend wir wollen
dorthin wo das haschisch produziert wird
von beirut aus reisen wir ins
libanesische hinterland
[Musik]
je weiter wir in die berge kommen umso
dichter hängen flaggen der hisbollah im
libanon eine regierungspartei die in
deutschland als terror-organisation gilt
und verboten ist
nach zweieinhalb stunden fahrt erreichen
wir ja mona 1 6000 einwohner dorf mitten
zwischen ackerflächen im dorf treffen
vitalife das dorf wird beherrscht von
einer familie dessen oberhaupt ist auch
vorsitzender der gemeinde
das problem ist bei 1000 quadratmetern
kartoffeln hast du viele risiken wasser
viel zeit
haschisch anzubauen ist also
risikofragen für den bau er erzählt
lieber als das haschisch während ihm
touristen
ich wäre gern ein touristischer ort das
wäre mein traum stadtarchiv hotels cafés
restaurants eröffnen
ich würde gerne die mentalität hier
ändern
doch die realität sieht anders aus
allein in diesen lagerraum
schätzungsweise 150 kilogramm haschisch
preis in deutschland circa 15 millionen
euro mit sieben verschiedener
maschenweiten wird harz von den
restlichen pflanzenteilen getrennt das
gewonnene harz pulver wird zur haschisch
gepresst bekannt als roter lieber nie
wenige häuser weiter das nächste lager
wahrscheinlich eine halbe tonne
haschisch
ein syrischer hilfsarbeiter beim 7
diesmal mit maschinen 20 tonnen
exportieren will ich erzählen wir
einwohner junge männer aus dem dorf
nehmen uns mit ausfällt vor der kamera
präsentieren sie ihre kalaschnikows und
demonstrieren was passiert wenn die
polizei kommen naja was passiert mit
jedem der unser land betritt und was ist
mit der hisbollah überall hier hängen
flaggen die gegend hier gehört server
aber sie können das nicht verbieten weil
dann wären sie in einem kampf mit ihren
eigenen leuten hier ist es so
der eine bruder arbeitet für die partei
der andere tasche
denkst du die beiden brüder würden
darüber streiten das würde sie doch
voneinander trennen ein rechtsfreier
raum in den großfamilien ihren
geschäften nachgehen geduldet von der
hisbollah
das geht schon seit jahrzehnten so
glaubt man den schilderungen von
großvater hat ich kenne europa ich war
sogar schon mal in frankfurt und münchen
früher brachte ich so 100 200 kilo mit
dem auto über die türkei oder per schiff
libanon italien und von da weiter nach
holland frankreich und deutschland
[Musik]
wir fahren weiter sind verabredet mit
einem mann der zum umfeld einer
kriminellen arabischen großfamilie in
berlin gehört zur zeit lebt er im
südlibanon
er will nicht erkannt werden galerie
gehört zum geschäft
aber haben es einfach im blut dieses
adrenalin und etwas krasses zu machen
das ist der grund warum in deutschland
die ausländer und die araber und die
libanesen die drogenmarkt in hand an
er kann erklären wie die geschäfte
ablaufen in deutschland werde das
haschisch mit großem gewinn verkauft das
geld werde gewaschen und fließe in form
von waren zurück in den libanon und die
leute kaufen zum beispiel irgendwelche
ware mit dem schicken die mit container
hierher kommen wird ja nichts
eingestellt das heißt alles was auch
deutsche kommt wird sie verwendet alles
auch taschen voller geld kämen direkt
aus deutschland
fest steht bis zu 10.000 euro pro person
sind nicht anmeldepflichtig und
kontrollen am flughafen finden nur
stichprobenartig statt jeden zweiten tag
eine fliege und die ehemalige wenn
jemand herkommt und sagt dann kannst du
mit 10.000 und 15.000 und 18.000
mitnehmen sozusagen meine familie viele
leute stoßen damit 30.000 alles aber
noch im grünen bereich und hat auch
immer wieder hier 200.000 so
funktioniert es zurück in deutschland
in berlin kennen die ermittler die
methoden der kampf dagegen sei schwierig
also sicherlich bekannt durch den
strafverfolgern das oft derartigen wegen
sicherlich gl geschmuggelt werden können
aber es gibt viel einfachere wege es
werden beträge überwiesen kreis von
personen die wir nicht kennen gerade
wenn sie das beispielsweise in kleineren
chargen überweisen dann greifen auch
diese verdachtsanzeigen nicht und so
wird das ganz schwierig sein diese
gelder aufzudecken
vergangenes jahr hat die politik die
strategie der tausend nadelstiche
ausgerufen
seitdem regelmäßige razzien
tatverdächtige sollen nicht zur ruhe
kommen
ob sie tatsächlich kriminelle strukturen
aufgebrochen werden also ein marathon
laufen wir sind gerade gestartet und die
andere seite hat einen ganz immensen
vorteil
das heißt der sport den im moment
anlegen der wirt zu kurzzeitigen
erfolgen führen
aber auch strecke müssen wir einfach
sehen dass wir tatsächlich diese
verfolgungs dichte und intensität
aufrechterhalten denn sonst nur dieses
projekt kläglich scheitern
all die maßnahmen werden nicht greifen
solange die nachfrage nach haschisch und
kokain ungebrochen ist
in berlin bietet der cowboy weiter druck
der hauptstadt tauber ist noch da wie
sieht es mit euch aus sollte schon am
comer see noch gas weltweit haben länder
drogen teilweise legalisiert ist das ein
sinnvoller weg um drogen kriminalität zu
bekämpfen schreibt eure meinung in die
kommentare